في الهزيمة ذهب الشجاعة
والغرور في هزيمة رجال
ما يسمى بالدولة الإسلامية ينحنون
رؤوسهم ويغطون وجوههم في التناقض الحاد
مع الانتصار الصارخ في
الأيام الأولى لداعش ، لم نتمكن من القتال بعد الآن ، لذلك
استسلمنا مايو السوري.  يقول في
الأيام القليلة الماضية
، استسلم المئات من مقاتلي داعش
للقوات الديمقراطية السورية المدعومة من الولايات المتحدة
، ولم يتخلى البعض بعد عن هذا الفيديو الذي تم تصويره
يوم الأربعاء من آخر جيب للتنظيم
يظهر رجالًا على الأقدام ودراجة نارية
يتحركون في وضح النهار
وهزموا داعش ربما حتى الآن  عمر ، وهو
لاجئ فلسطيني نشأ في سوريا
، لم يتخلى عن اعترافه بالهزيمة اليوم ،
ولكن ليس غدًا ربما حكم الأمريكيون
العالم اليوم كما أخبرني ولكن
الله تعالى وعد المسلمين أنه
في النهاية سيحكم
الإسلام دولتهم.  قريبون من الموت
لا اوهامهم الرحمن رغم الحرب
وكل المشاكل المفروضة عليها
اعتقد ان الدولة الاسلامية كانت ناجحة
كما تعلم ساندي روكي تخبرني لا احد
أعطتها الفرصة لتقديم أي
شيء للعالم ، فالدولة التي ادعى فيها الرجال أنهم
يحكمون باسم الله
والمطاعونة على شفا الانقراض ،
والأطفال والنساء يدفعون
الثمن غارقين في ذهول ومشوشين
جائعين وعطش.  التدافع على
شاحنات تستخدم عادة لنقل
الماشية المتجهة إلى المخيمات إلى الشمال
في حالة بؤس الهزيمة هو نصيبهم